lori lightfoot isn't doing anything to
stop the madness she's too busy telling
us if we can take a bite out of our
muffins without spreading covet
raymond lopez is a chicago city alderman
and he joins me now so raymond
she's basically willing to sacrifice the
lives of her own constituents
last year just so she could look tough
against that mean mean man donald trump
what a scoundrel is she seen as a
scoundrel in chicago by most people
well jesse first off merry christmas and
yes most chicago ones do not find it the
least bit hip find it very much
hypocritical that the mayor 15 months
ago told donald trump to get the hell
out of chicago with his assistance and
basically pay politics with people's
lives and here we are in 2021 over 812
people murdered by gun violence in the
city of chicago that number continues to
rise we've seen more children impacted
by gun violence than by kovid and now
she's doing the great pivot the great
about face and saying now that president
joe biden is here she'll take the help
what about all those thousands of people
whose lives have been impacted by gun
violence or the lives that were lost
last year when she could have had help
from the federal government
won't talk about it won't apologize for
it and just wishes to sweep it under the
rug as though it never happened
are you saying more children in chicago
have died from bullets than have died
from covid19
more children have been victimized by
gun violence in the city of chicago
than have been killed by covet in the
entire state of illinois in the last
year the entire state of illinois it's
astounding
um and yet we still talk more about
covid than we do gun violence absolutely
why not it distracts from all the
bloodshed
have you heard anything from barack
obama does he ever talk about the surge
in homicides i mean this guy's hometown
i mean i know he lives in the vineyard
in hawaii now but do you ever hear him
implore the leaders of his hometown to
do something
about the violence
you know even as
president obama works on building his
obama center in woodlawn and as many of
our
city officials are joining the biden
administration
the fact that we have one of the most
perceived violent cities in america
seems to be lost on all of them
and
every day residents throughout the city
of chicago are struggling they feel that
they are quite literally under the gun
every time they step out of their homes
whether it's to take their kids to
school whether it's to go to work or
whether it's just to take a walk around
the block
children
working parents and even our seniors
are all a threat of being victimized
every day in this city with no one
wanting to take responsibility
for it or to propose real solutions
other than blaming someone else as we
heard from lightfoot this week
and what we're seeing right now
is that the pendulum that many
democratic politicians and i will say as
a democrat i find it
disgusting that we're at this point but
they've pushed the pendulum so far to
the left when it comes to criminal
justice reform that we now favor
criminals over victims
and that even as the politicians are
becoming victims themselves i'm more
than certain they will never accept
responsibility for the seeds that
they've sown to bring us to this point
even after getting carjacked at gunpoint
they're still
not going to change their position it's
unbelievable but at this point it's not
surprising thank you so much alderman
raymond lopez
thank you jesse hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else